Londres no solo Corona al próximo jefe
de estado del Reino Unido también espera
en el contexto de la ceremonia una
inyección económica sobre la base del
turismo Y es que antes de la investidura
oficial del Rey Carlos III hoteles bares
y restaurantes ya ofrecían paquetes
temáticos esto con el objetivo de atraer
la atención de las cientos de miles de
personas que se esperan en Londres
durante el covid la Industria Del
turismo simplemente cerró por lo tanto
la industria sufrió pérdidas alrededor
de 149 mil millones de libras eventos
como este realmente impulsan la
recuperación no y colocan a Reino Unido
nuevamente en el escenario mundial
Claudia es una de las turistas que
impulsa el crecimiento proveniente de
Bélgica llevó su madre a disfrutar del
autobús del té
porque sí también es una oportunidad
única en la vida disfrutar de la
coronación de Carlos
sí siempre recordaremos la coronación
del Rey tercero así
iniciativas como estas abundan en la
urbe otros sitios ofrecen el té
preferido del monarca
Así que hemos hecho un pastel de té Dark
gilling los curiosos no pasan por alto
la oportunidad de tomarlo adornado con
un arreglo especial pero no todo es
alegría una inflación galopante afecta
el costo de vida en el único país de
Europa que no ha logrado recuperar sus
niveles económicos prepandémicos
sectores de la sociedad han salido a las
calles para reclamar mejores salarios
incluso quienes custodian el aeropuerto
han planeado retirarse en el contexto de
la Asunción de Carlos una forma de
llamar la atención que busca paralizar
la llegada de Los Seguidores de la
corona británica